he is pro football talks mike florio how
are you mike i'm doing great rich and
today is so crazy i will admit to you
freely and i currently seek
the forgiveness of
the folks at nbc news i double booked
and you won oh the face off okay oh did
you tell first i rarely double book but
when i do it's first in first out isn't
it
hold on a second did you tell hallie
jackson to pound sand is that what you
did on msnbc
your passport might get revoked she
knows people man yeah i know i know
careful
well i appreciate that and they're still
i've let them know i double booked and
they're still texting me frantically so
this is an interesting few minutes
what are my commitments specifically the
commitments i make before i make other
conflicting commitments
mike florio pro football talk highly in
demand uh making his appointed round
here on the rich eisen show okay so what
what happened um
mike to cause john gruden to
um stick with um you know his i guess
black better phrases guns
uh last week uh and then last night
basically say i'm done what happened
well it's stunning to me rich because
when the nfl acknowledged the situation
on friday and it was kind of a strange
timeline the wall street journal broke
the story about the one email
that referred to demora smith the nflpa
executive director with the racist trope
but
there was also
a statement from the league in the wall
street journal's article and there was
an acknowledgment that there are more
items there are more materials that were
sent to the raiders
and it became clear to me last night and
as this was all unfolding kind of minute
by minute shefty was on the monday night
countdown show
saying that the league sent even more
materials on monday to the raiders and
the league is waiting for the raiders
next move and
then the new york times article drops
and it drops with a very loud explosion
that results in gruden resigning within
an hour and i think it was very simple
rich
they were hoping that gruden would walk
away or that mark davis would fire him
and
when they didn't pick up on that fairly
obvious nuance to all of this when you
send these materials there's one piece
that's been leaked there's other pieces
that haven't been leaked when they don't
figure out that the next phase of this
is
some of this other stuff is going to get
leaked then you leak some of it and
that's when i think john gruden realized
oh
all this stuff's going to eventually
come out i better just walk away and
there's probably more they're just not
in a position now to have any incentive
to leak it and gruden if he would have
quit friday night or saturday or sunday
or even yesterday morning all we would
have ever known about is the one
email that was leaked to the wall street
journal last week so i think this was a
deliberate effort by someone to get john
gruden out of that job either via
resignation or termination
you know i mean i i i kind of went all
in on it in the first segment of the
show i didn't even give the the usual
that i've you know i've known john and
i've been around him you know he worked
at the nfl network before he went to
espn and i didn't see any anything
any this behavior never heard that
language before i didn't even i don't
even give that one i just
you know even though that is true i've
never heard him say anything like that
i i just couldn't believe what i was
reading last night just that that
is this basically you know in your your
estimation the tip of an iceberg you
just mentioned that there you could be
more what what what what else do you
think was was said in these emails and
why why only leak about gruden well
there could be more prudent emails that
are just other examples of the stuff
that we're now aware of but you know on
one hand you could look at this as
gruden's the outlier on the other hand
you'd look you could look at it and say
well this is just indicative of anyone
and everyone who's involved in the nfl
in some capacity or instead of guessing
we could
see what's there in this 650 000 email
trove that the nfl initially buried
underground 300 feet like nuclear waste
back in july that's where this all
started rich and look the nfl
which understands pr as well as any
major corporation they knew when to drop
the results of the washington football
team investigation late afternoon on
thursday july 1. when july 4 lands on a
sunday what happens it's a four-day
weekend by tuesday the sixth
everyone had forgotten and no one was
saying now wait a minute you're telling
me
you did an investigation that lasted for
over a year and you didn't ask the
lawyer to prepare a written report that
never happens lawyers get hired to
investigate they prepare a written
report they document their findings and
you're never going to release any of
this and there's no transparency and
we're not going to find out what was
learned from all these interviews and
they had some cockamamie excuse like
well we promised confidentiality to some
of the alleged accusers well that
doesn't mean you can't still release
information and protect the
identity of people who made accusations
that happens all the time but it all
went away but now they go back to that
well for just a few little pieces a few
pages
because they have some other agenda that
they need to fulfill
and i i don't know
because a lot of people are onto this
now and i'm hearing from readers and
viewers who otherwise wouldn't care
about these kinds of machinations
they're like wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
how does gruden become the one
who gets singled out to have his emails
exposed when he wasn't even working for
the team and all the other stuff's going
to be hidden and that's not a defense of
gruden it's a recognition of
you can't hide the iceberg there is an
iceberg you can't just say
well gruden did this and gruden did that
and gruden good and gruden and forget
about everything else what did daniel
snyder say in emails sent to bruce allen
there's a lot of nervous people around
the league today rich
because bruce allen knew a lot of people
and bruce allen emailed with a lot of
people and there's people in the league
office that are nervous about this
because they emailed with bruce allen
and i say they i know of one that i'm
not going to disclose for now
but there's nervous people out there
well let's see all of it it's not fair
to us to gruden to anyone
to have us guess what else is out there
they have it and we know they have it
because they leaked
this stuff that relates to john green or
at least some of that stuff mike florio
profo took pro football talk here on the
rich eisen show
and now now now let's get to the what
next for the raiders
um what a job um now to try and clean
this up
you know and uh that locker room must be
filled with tons of players who feel
violated you know what i mean like for
the the
the players of color
for carl nasib for the players that were
rallying around their teammates of color
and carl nasib um to to to think that
was gruden full of it the entire time
you know and that's going to be
something if john wants to deal with
with these men to try and and and and
rectify in the middle of a season that
just
eight days ago when they took to the
field here in los angeles and so far
they were three and oh and we're talking
about a super bowl potential campaign
for this team
i i i cannot imagine what is the plan do
you think here
to try and rectify all this coaching
staff and and everything else i'm not
sure what you can do i mean gruden's
gone and he isn't going to be back rich
versace takes over but versace has got
ties to gruden if i'm a player on that
locker room i look at versace and say
well why should i regard him any
differently right now than i would
regard john gruden which guy on this
staff can i trust which guy can i not
trust how many of these guys are just
like gruden and here's the problem with
groot and this goes back years chris
sims talked about it today on pft live
he played for gruden in tampa bay
2003-2006 and i used to do weekly radio
with steve dumig he passed away a couple
of years ago but
dumig told me back when gruden was the
buccaneers coach that he had a
well-earned reputation for saying one
thing doing another being extremely and
blatantly two-faced and sims tells those
stories how
he'll be talking about a guy and saying
horrible things about him and the guy
walks into the room hey man i love you
you're my guy players are smart enough
to figure that out
and that reputation hung with gruden his
entire time as a head coach and i think
that's part of the confusion now for the
players who maybe weren't clued into
that yet who hadn't been around long
enough to understand it they're going to
be confused and i think the question
becomes in whom do you put your trust
now that gruden is gone but all the guys
gruden hired to help him coach are still
there that's going to be the challenge
is getting
getting those players to turn the page
on john gruden and it becomes a
challenge for mark davis it becomes a
challenge for mike mayok it becomes a
challenge to rich versace and everyone
else in the power structure there exact
you know because you and i were were
banding at about first blush last night
on halftime on the westwood one monday
night football broadcast you know gus
bradley was a name that we brought up
and
you know he he's one of those sunny
disposition you know high-energy
pete carroll type guys
that i'm i'm wondering if they didn't
turn to him because you know obviously
he has head coaching experience in
jacksonville because the defense has
gone so well with him
locking down on that that they don't
want him now handling all phases and
figuring out when to call time-outs and
things like that right maybe that was
the decision i i guess that's it but
rich he's one of the few guys on that
staff that i think the locker room would
look to and say he's really not a
quote-unquote
guy he's the guy who was brought in
after the first gruden guy was made a
scapegoat because the defense wasn't
good enough and paul gunther got thrown
overboard so gus bradley is the guy to
come fix it i mean bradley and gruden
were together for five games and i think
bradley would have had an easier time
than versace to get the players at large
to to distinguish and differentiate and
distance
gruden from the assistant head coach
that really to me and i haven't thought
about it until we have had this
conversation but
i don't know that versace is the right
choice just from that standpoint i think
you need distance from gruden or you're
still going to have guys in the locker
room
not really understanding what the hell
is going on and it doesn't take much to
throw a guy off when you're talking
about these very physical and
emotionally draining games that we see
teams playing each and every week one
after another
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
um okay so where where
where do things stand i guess with urban
meyer uh because you know he was the
coach uh that we were talking quite a
bit about
about him potentially being
a game or two away from having a a very
long relationship that we all assumed
was going to blossom uh cut short
um shockingly
uh get cut shockingly short you know now
here's gruden for obviously different
reasons
um out
what is going on with urban in
jacksonville right now as they head to
london which you know is a bermuda
triangle for
hot seat coaches oh absolutely and
especially with the buy on the back end
and for most of these london games the
teams that play in them have a buy right
after that and that that creates the the
perfect storm for a coaching change to
be made
it it was only 12 days ago and my god it
seems like 12 months ago that urban
meyer did not accompany his team from
cincinnati back to jacksonville and
that's the unforgivable sin in my mind
that's the abandonment of his post tony
dungy explained it so well to me on
sunday you know it's not just a matter
of failing to go back with the team
and be with them
elbow to elbow arm and arm as they
process this disappointing loss and then
get back to work with those three extra
days because you're going to need them
with the titans coming to town as we
obviously saw but it's about
responsibility for your team what if
there's a fight among players on that
plane what if there's an argument what
if one of the players decides he's going
to speak his mind to one of the
assistant coaches where's the head coach
he's responsible for everything what if
the flight gets diverted because of
weather what if somebody has a heart
attack on the plane what if there's any
anything that can happen where's the
captain he's nowhere to be found and to
me that's the thing that is going to
haunt urban meyer forever and
i know the people in the organization
have been watching two things rich
one whether to what extent urban meyer
told the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth when he was
questioned last monday by owner shad
khan and what are the jaguars doing
to confirm or debunk whatever story he
provided and then number two what
happens next what's the next thing that
shows urban meyers not fit to be an nfl
coach i mean
yesterday he was talking about they hope
to have 250 yards rushing in 250 yards
passing every week which shows he has no
understanding of how the nfl works
that's never happened it's only happened
in a given game 33 times since the
merger nobody's averaging 250 rushing
250 passing and it just it just
underscores that that he thinks it's
ohio state versus rutgers each and every
week even after he's gotten his butt
kicked five straight weeks
by teams that aren't among the very best
in the nfl so i i
i think that it's not over
whether it's after the london game
whether it's after the season or
somewhere in between it just feels like
this all is pointing to one and done or
maybe less than one and done for urban
meyer you know and i also because i
pointed out to my guy brockman here
who's got a uh 18 months cage at home
right now 19 now mike so you understand
you know that it it struck me when urban
said we're desperate and then trevor
lawrence like yeah we're not desperate
and he's like yeah well we didn't sneak
it because he's not comfortable being
under center you know being a college
kid
coming into the pros and all and he's
like you know i'm comfortable with it
like that struck me as like when when my
kid's trying to split my wife and i uh
on a decision you know at home and susie
and i my wife and i we have to get on
the same page before we talk to the kids
you know and it's just like it's it's a
it's a rule of tentative parenting
and coaching is kind of like parenting
and the fact that they're not on the
same page after that loss as well and
they're heading to london
where shad khan as we all know is a as
my parents would say in the house he's a
big macho there in london you know
they're playing in his building for
crying out loud
trent kramer the independents and all
that world from treadless are gonna be
asking questions of urban that this has
at all the makings of the tinderbox
and even though the cons and urban are
hoping this is just going to pass and
they can get back to business of trying
to grow this franchise i don't
i don't see it is what i'm saying right
now no you're right and the question
becomes at what point does shot khan
recognize through his own ego and vanity
that he made a mistake and we see that
in the nfl all the time and the best
coaches the best executives the best
owners understand that if you've made a
mistake the best thing you can do is
admit it to yourself and everyone else
because if you double down and triple
down it only gets worse it doesn't
suddenly
turn around
and i i think that
that's what some of the folks in the
jaguars organization are watching and
waiting for now will shot khan admit it
because he's wanted urban meyer for like
a decade of course why not and why not
and why not that's why i'm so surprised
about this i really am and you know i've
got a bunch of college people and i'm
sure you do too and who are who got
their ears to the ground they're saying
why are you so surprised like you know
there's always been drama everywhere
he's been and i'm like but i can't
believe that it's no team playing video
comes out um you know uh
and and the warning signs were stuff
like what i thought was kind of funny
that he told vic fangio that everybody's
alabama here in the nfl you know like
i'm i am kind of surprised we're in this
position with him six weeks in i am but
i'm not because for a guy who was never
an nfl coach
in any way shape or form and i know
here's what happens whether it's chip
kelly whether it's greg ciano whether
it's urban meyer whoever it is when that
college coach shows up
i think a lot of people in our business
assume that he's going to be the next
jimmy johnson
and
praise him as if he's going to be the
next jimmy johnson and hope to expand
their potential access to him in the
event he becomes the next jimmy johnson
that there isn't enough healthy cynicism
to say
here's another one who's over his skis
here's another one who doesn't get it
here's another one who hasn't worked in
the world of grown ass men
and thinks he can just show up and coach
these guys like he coached in college i
didn't mention steve spurrier i mean
meyer is far closer to spurrier than
jimmy johnson meyer's a guy who thinks
you can keep bankers hours
and you can check out and let the staff
keep working and there's not going to be
any resentment whatsoever about that
then you barnstorm in and you undermine
this position coach and that position
coach in front of the players and
there's all sorts of stories like that
going around
meyer thinks he can operate at the nfl
level like he did at the college level
and he fails to understand the very
fundamental differences and he doesn't
have the curiosity i think he believes
through his own force of will he can
bend the nfl reality his way and make it
like a college game and it's asinine to
think that that's even a possibility
because you can't go out and recruit
superior talent and just line them up
and let them do a thing you can call out
the play hey defense here's what we're
going to do good luck stopping it that
doesn't work at the nfl level and it's
those nuances it's that work it's the
study it's the strategizing it's why
bill belichick has to change the name of
his boat every few years from five rings
to six rings to eight rings because he's
the guy who is the platinum standard
when it comes to the connection between
what you put in and what you get out
meyer's not putting enough in plain and
simple he's not putting enough in mike
appreciate the time uh say hi to nicole
wallace and you're make good on msnbc
later okay
take care thank you mike floria
everybody at pro football talk
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here